[Music]
reading also the snake said hey try
eating this Apple it'll make everyone
look even more like an asshole
CGI serpent that looks like just another
studio logo is actually part of the film
Sunday School movies casual disdain for
the Oxford comma is disheartening
Aronofsky movies intro directed by Zack
Snyder no one sees Noah running and
hiding discount unobtainium old tiny
biblical Dragonscale dog thing Russell
Crowe discovers his Australian roots and
goes full Crocodile Dundee with this
fictional scaly dog apparently everyone
from the land of Cain is evil somehow
not one good person was born over there
this entire time some of you may not
know but Noah was the first Jason Bourne
in history vegetarianism hi honey how
was your day well I killed three men and
buried a dragon dog you know the usual
the sheer curtain is all that separates
you from seeing your parents doing it
previously in the beginning like dream
no exception it's going to destroy the
book wow you had a dream about being
underwater with dying people and that's
what you took from it maybe you were
just gonna be in the Triwizard
Tournament you know even though all
these characters are gonna age ten years
before the actual flood but whatever and
that's where between a rock and a hard
place comes from kids also this is the
gets hit with a shotgun thing from every
other movie only Noah should be even
more dead wait all that dragging and
scraping his face on the ground and not
one mark on his face aren't you rock
guys fallen angels isn't that exactly
what you guys did despite Leamas ear on
this child still wants Russell Crowe to
sing to her
he punished us we were encrusted by you
world yet Cain commits murder and is
allowed to go make babies and create
entire cities and stuff exposition by
giant monster walk and talk
Sorkin would be proud convenient lineage
is convenient to most of us
how do you kill angels made at Bronx
also this watcher explodes for no reason
he must have changed these plans for
noah and then thought you know if he can
somehow get this vision and build an ark
that can hold two of every animal this
just might work
Methuselah rupees his own grandson
rather than the voice of God in this
movie Noah acts on the events he sees in
a lucid dream brought about by tea
poisoning but probably still got right
destroy saw only just Todd again as we
all know this worked out for the best
we've been chosen to save the innocent
animals who refers to animals as the
innocent and by the way it was a snake
that started all this right our snakes
innocent to dust okay I'll start on the
sand castle you get to work on the
skyscraper and the women will start
building oh you've met an ark didn't you
oh he's burying that seed Methuselah
gave him now I personally wanted to
assume it was meant to be planted after
the flood but maybe that's only because
Methuselah gave no instructions about
the seed at all deus ex machina with
seeds this powerful it's kind of a
wonder God needs Noah's help to do well
anything also it's too bad that the Eden
seed that built this forest didn't also
just go ahead and build an ark too well
it was at it this seems kind of small to
me but maybe I'm overestimating the size
of lions and tigers and bears oh my
even with all these rock monsters
helping out the Ark still took eight
years or more to get to this point
Wow this biblical story about the
god-fearing Noah and his children just
got a whole lot sexier flying birds
signified danger cliche
yes yeah they're swirling overhead dude
hard to miss shouldn't the birds
basically go last we have to fit several
metric tons of elephants and kangaroos
in this thing before we start worrying
about the small animals after the storm
they'll become a mother and a father and
the chunks will spread right across the
world now don't ask me how the
hatchlings will continue to reproduce
after that because that's an x-files
episode waiting to happen
Percy Jackson isn't something something
in this movie sorry I only barely paid
attention to those movies so I don't
really know what he does but he's not
doing it here all the votes or two so
are you saying he'll send a girl for me
when I need one or are you saying he's
already sent everything we need and I'm
basically in terms of a love life
me too sure why not they've never done
any major biblical harm to humans thus
far plus they'll take care of the mice
oh wait
something dramatic is about to happen
during the seemingly harmless stuffing
leaves in a sack sequence powdered ham
and Japeth amidst this entire throng of
people walking through the woods also
why aren't there giant pea Turgeon
spiders guarding the forest and keeping
these guys out or elves or ents anything
ever created that keeps people out of
dark forests in the Lord of the Rings or
Maleficent so was tubal-cain although
it's not the same Lamech see people this
is why we need last names I'm not alone
well I guess this was the perfect time
for the Watchers to be sleeping so that
they could dramatically rise and scare
all these people why weren't they
working on the ark no wonder this thing
is taking years to build there's no skin
for you and yokai well that's only true
because they're lazy honestly wants to
prevent these people from building their
own Ark with all these trees that are
still left over they also have way more
manpower and could finish earlier if
they wanted we build an ark first
weapons then bang oh we're gonna need a
bigger boat these animals built the
scale or is the Ark way bigger than I
think it is yellow would be excellent at
cinemasins also he didn't your ass isn't
in the Bible
you're just added on for eye candy and
crucial plot swings also how do you know
you're barren
let's see Bank countless dudes
unprotected how do you know this for a
fact these guys set a trap and thank the
creator noah convene a season but
there's absolutely no danger of traps
after this until ham finds an
inconvenient girlfriend
man cannibalism rape forced prostitution
famine disease murder this camp is an
orgy of evidence that there is a dawn of
sin in this camp damn is this a dream -
he even dreamed to that spring-loaded
trap earlier was that some sort of
symbolism watch out for the trap Noah
soon will getcha wait was that not a
dream was it a combination what was the
point of that giveaway wife material
what do you want liar let this be a
lesson boys if you give a girl food
instead of killing her in the dead body
pit she's yours for the rest of her
short life don't fire them and bring
them back um why not send a couple rock
monsters instead I mean you go on to say
be careful so you know the request is
dangerous seems like a rock monster
would have an easier time not getting
killed you just believed this ELA is a
terrible tracker and instead of ham or
the entire human civilization just
meters from the ark site she finds a
barren woods with Methuselah in it moon
bloom rustling wind indicates something
mystical is happening cliche you can go
now you may commence with the hot
biblical nailing it's as God intended I
will miss him time to immediately bang
maybe your image why will you go first
with me maybe on the murder and the
rampaging just a guess
also it rains for two minutes and this
asshole is already yelling at God
convinced Noah's Flood talk was legit
this weapon exists also hella this
weapon exists why did they even bother
with training they could have just built
a bunch of these and waxed a whole bunch
of Watchers without even losing a man
right
because battle is the only way Hollywood
knows how to build tension let's
shoehorn an evil army into the Noah
story since a world covering flood isn't
antagonists enough where's ham ham man
we hit that salami oh you meant the
brother no idea I know we need a cool
shot but were they screaming the entire
way to Noah's Ark and why Noah ex
machina Noah and his son get swallowed
by the massive soldiers who evidently
forgot they were on their way to kill
Noah and his son this is really cool but
while everyone was busy thinking about
fornicating for 10 years they could have
build a nice little moat or a trench or
something to prevent an easy passage of
evil humans from even getting to the ark
site how would a dozen giant rock
monsters have any trouble at all with
any sized human army their fallen angels
and their King rocks man you know when I
heard Darren Aronofsky king of the
discomforting downtrodden man stories
was making a Noah movie I definitely
wasn't expecting a CGI Lord of the Rings
ripoff extravaganza that's for sure
funny I didn't see that other Watchers
angel flying to the sky earlier I guess
it's because he didn't have the time to
ask for forgiveness before he exploded
there are entirely too many of these
assholes to properly fight them off and
we're led to believe that only one of
them makes it on the ark man Noah's a
better fighter than Maximus I bet if
Hollywood made a biblical epic about
Zacchaeus he'd be a kung fu fighting
expert slash tax collector suicide
solution okay maybe we could have done
that a little earlier just in case you
were wondering about Methuselah is
never-ending quest for berries while the
ark is under siege is pretty much no way
tubal-cain could have ray winstone size
hole in time to enter the ark in the
beginning there was nothing
previously in the bible he gave them a
choice but why why was there forbidden
fruit in the first place it kind of
seems like God set them up to fail I
think a decent lawyer could successfully
argue entrapment this parable Noah
relates also include several generations
after the fact including modern-day and
he saw that it was good
creators judged us mankind must end this
is something based on a loose
interpretation of a dream I had and I
also could have told you this before
but drama it's a big art I know but Noah
isn't doing rounds he's not checking the
boat for leaks or human stowaways I'm
really not to be what he wanted a world
without the Creator leaves crucial
information to the ark plan open for
interpretation and guy eats one of the
art creatures which I can only assume
means it's a creature we've never known
of in our culture since you know he ate
one of them and it probably couldn't
make probably a Pegasus or something
amazing
this blanket biblical first response a
couple of dots and a few specks means
you're pregnant a couple of specks and a
few dots means you're not it was
confusing back then you just saw a
forest grow out of one seed and a bunch
of animals board the ark without an
announcement impossible shouldn't be in
your vocabulary you just saw a forest
grow out of one seed and a bunch of
animals I asked the creation well you
only told us what God's plan was after
we got on the ark so also that asshole
was out looking for berries the whole
time I guess hoping that Allah would
show up so that he could magically heal
her to do nothing since whatever baby is
in her my knees wound will never be able
to get married or have children of its
own without failure good I would not
fail you got it oh god damn it there's a
girl who could move into a mother died I
just can't trust ham not to bang his
niece I see that 40 days and 40 nights
turned into a full-term pregnancy
somehow then wake another one that can
find us a home mom thinks son can tell
hyper-intelligent Birds apart from
regular birds oh this domestic dispute
just got a whole lot sexier I think how
was Gila this pregnant and tubal Cain
still hasn't done anything
and no one still hasn't seen him each
time it's actually long past time also
he must have eaten like half the species
on this boat already you mean to tell me
he was content with eating a veggie diet
after he took a bite out of that lizard
thing he ate a few months ago hey this
birthing scene just got a whole lot
sexier wait damn man you had the
advantage and we stood it on this you
had nine months to plant back in
biblical times there was no such thing
as an umbilical cord sisters so twin
sisters the heavy implication is that
both ham and japheth have future wives
here and I'm just speechless
when I killed your father but you didn't
see him when he was a kid did you this
movie had us believe that no one was
hiding so well you never saw him I love
how this entire story comes down to the
two characters not in the original
narrative asshole army dude and not
Baron Hermione
because a story about a man building a
giant boat on God's instructions then
loading that boat with two of every
animal and his family then surviving a
worldwide flood is an exciting enough
material to make a movie out of on its
own apparently Tara ex machina what do
you mean you care who kills Noah you
have this outstanding yearning for
revenge where only you can kill him
what the hell then do it already
ham surprise change of Allegiance is a
surprise only to those in the audience
just now watching a movie for the first
time you've just made a big deal about
making your kids stop crying before they
die and now you just yell and the babies
amazingly don't wake up Noah immense
drunkenness and wine and new beaches
crave you learn to be kind we do not so
I say to you be fruitful and multiply
somehow
[Music]
but still ritual requires we continue
with the number of platonic activities
before we have sex you can just slap me
now how is that result this is something
used to sing me sometimes they are in
good hands they look like good strong
don't they chin up to the ground come a
bubble improve all that is black gold
Texas tea
[Music]
sorry I'll be back
Hey